pop culture and I am talking about no
soda pop culture though early onset
diabetes is a serious issue plaguing
your society today I am talking about
pop culture references and dragonball
talking about diabetes just now akira
toriyama is a major cinephile and
despite admitting to not reading a lot
of manga or watching a lot of anime has
created one of the biggest and most
prolific Japanese franchises and ip's
ever and you better believe there are
tons of references to all the things
that curatorial loves and enjoys from
the west to the east and for your
viewing pleasure I've spent my limited
time on this planet looking for the 15
best pop culture Easter eggs in the
entire Dragon Ball series let's begin to
begin this list let's take a look at
what I was unsure on for quite some time
you see some speculated that the
hyperbolic time chamber or room of
spirit and time might have been a
reference to the white void area from
the film th x - 1 138 catchy titles
aside the movie is a 1971 sci-fi fantasy
film set in a dystopian future written
edited and directed by George Lucas
before he created the Star Wars
franchise which Akira Toriyama was a
huge fan of along with the rest of the
world despite the white void area
looking strikingly similar to the
hyperbolic time chamber in design I
still wasn't convinced until I heard
this this quote takes place as two of
the prisoners are walking further and
further out into the ether of the void
and as many Dragon Ball fans might
remember these are similar attributes
associated with the hyperbolic time
chamber jumping from an incredibly
obscure film from the 70s to a massively
popular one from the 50s we find
ourselves with Disney's Cinderella it's
a known fact that while Akira Toriyama
loved his sci-fi and his Asian martial
arts films he also enjoyed Disney from
time to time and anyone who has seen
Cinderella knows this
those three words sound familiar poverty
is the shriveled up prune that tries to
awaken majin buu and bibbidi is Baba
Dee's father man akira toriyama sure
does love his strange naming conventions
but from there let's jump into some of
Akira Toriyama's bigger passions martial
arts films did you know that Akira
Toriyama and Jackie Chan were actually
fans of one another Toriyama was such a
big fan of these martial arts films that
in the first tournament arc of the
original Dragon Ball Master Roshi
disguises himself as a character called
Jackie Chun obviously a name derived
from Jackie Chan with his design being
inspired by the late Bruce Lee so from
the early stages of Dragonball let's
jump to the beginning of Dragon Ball Z's
Saiyan saga and it just so happens this
section of the story has quite a few
references and parallels to the movie
Superman to a child sent to earth from a
planet destined for destruction raised
in a simple humble setting eventually
fighting in defense of Earth against the
superior ranked individual from his home
planet I mean it's clear here that
Vegeta is Zod minor side note dr. slump
another akira toriyama manga had a
character called superman which was
obviously inspired by superman both in
name and design fun fact though the name
superman translates to sour man in
english skipping forward from the Saiyan
saga to the Namek saga there are a few
references to Ridley Scott's horror
masterpiece alien the most obvious of
which being freezes third form this is
clearly a homage to the xenomorph from
the Alien franchise everyone knows this
one I think I even know people who
haven't even seen dragon ball that know
about this one but it's still a good
reference however a less obvious
reference might be seen when looking at
freezes brother cooler yes despite not
being involved with the film's story or
anything like that Akira Toriyama did
design cooler and his subsequent forms
and his final forms designed if you look
closely could potentially be a homage to
the predator franchise there are some
striking similarities here this would
complement his brother xenomorph
reference nicely if it is true stick
with the Namek saga the time spent on
the trip to Namak for Bulma go on and
krillen is by no means a favorite part
of the story for anyone anyone that I
know anyway the only portion of this
section of the story that people enjoy
is the bull ma half nude scenes and
despite this section being supremely
uninteresting it also bears a striking
resemblance to the final scene of the
alien movie where Ripley is found
wearing a rider similar outfit seems
like bull mo was a fan and while we're
on the topic of this skimpy outfit it's
not the only time Dragonball made this
very reference to the character Ripley
nope
in fact it was a reference much much
earlier on the 17th episode of Dragon
Ball we can clearly see launch wearing
the same garments
I think the boma one is more convincing
seeing as they are also in space oh well
who here likes Power Rangers almost
everyone at some stage watched or
enjoyed some Power Rangers well these
Power Rangers are actually taken from or
inspired by a Japanese property called
Super Sentai in which a lot of the early
footage of the Power Rangers while in
their power suits were the original
Japanese recordings and actors fighting
inside I can't believe you had lied to
me Billy tangents aside Akira Toriyama
was also a big fan of these
larger-than-life character groups so
much so he managed to write into the
story flamboyant groups like the ginyu
force and more recently Universal Evans
Pride troopers sticking to the theme of
arcs being references to popular movie
franchises many aspects of the Android
saga are inspired or directly
referencing the Terminator franchise
from the 80s and 90s with Terminator 2
having been an enormous hit around the
world during the time the Android saga
was being written and produced it stands
to reason why it might have influenced
Akira Toriyama for God's sake trunks is
design is based off of John Connor look
at that hair and I don't think I need to
point out that Android 16 looks
strikingly similar to a certain Austrian
film star for now let's take a break
from the 80's and 90's and jump right
back up to the modern day with the
Dragon Ball super in 2017 two characters
were introduced to the world
sentient universe 11 as it's gonna
destruction and it's angel comes Belmont
and margarita immediately it should be
evident that both are references to the
Joker and Harley Quinn from the DC
Batman series sticking with the modern
incarnation let's take a look at one of
the more divisive characters to be
introduced to the series
Kayle Kayle herself is a reference to an
older Dragon Ball character called
growling who actually got his own cannon
appearance this year however that isn't
why Kael has made her way unto this list
it is in fact her reference to the first
Avengers film Kael in her hulking
muscular form while smashing Goku around
is a direct reference to the Hulk and
Loki scene where he gets yeah
flashing backwards from something new to
something old once again we find
ourselves on chapter 71 of the manga
Krillin and lunch are after returning to
Master Roshi's home with some groceries
all seems innocent and normal until you
realize one thing the bag reads Super
Mario which is obviously a reference to
the Super Mario videogame
patio oh here's a fun one did you know
that King Kai's monkey bubbles is named
after a celebrity of sorts or at least
he was a celebrity in the eighties a
celebrity pet a pet that once belonged
to the late Michael Jackson on top of
leading one of the most eccentric lives
perhaps ever owning his own theme park
and zoo on his own property he also was
the proud owner of a chimp that went by
the name of bubbles and finally our last
one perhaps the most obscure reference
in all of Dragonball literally a blink
and you miss it moment and boy is this
one nerdy at the 16-minute mark during
Dragon Ball Z episode 22 you might
notice a news helicopter nothing special
about it really it doesn't even make a
reappearance as it is later destroyed by
nappa
what is special about it however is that
serial number on this side of the
aircraft throw that code into Google and
you find that it is a reference to Star
Trek specifically NCC one seven zero one
a is a reference to a shuttlecraft from
the enterprise a I have never seen Star
Trek but there it is these were my
favorite pop-culture references in
Dragon Ball
your favorite if so let me know down
below in the comment section and who
knows I might update this video with the
sequel if I get enough suggestions don't
forget to leave a like or dislike on
this video and if you would like to see
more videos like this one consider
subscribing and turning that
notification on if you want the
subscription tour catch you guys in the
next video thank you so much for
watching